(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] A copy of "War and Peace,"
a pack of ham with the
word peace written on it
and a sheet of paper with asterisks.
- I was arrested just for 30 seconds.
- [Narrator] Holding
items like these in public
could get you in trouble
with authorities in Russia
under new legislation
introduced in recent weeks.
- What we're seeing now is a near wipe out
of any ability to speak out.
(lively music)
- [Narrator] Moscow puts much effort
into presenting a well-curated image
of the war to the population.
(solider speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The message inside Russia
is that its soldiers are defending
the Ukrainian population
from their own army and government.
Attempts to question it have been stifled.
The Wall Street Journal
reviewed police documents
and spoke with people inside Russia
to understand how far the Kremlin is going
to control the public's perception
of the war in Ukraine.
(people chanting in foreign language)
- [Narrator] In the early
days of the invasion,
people took to the streets across Russia
to protest but within weeks,
most of the visible signs
of dissent had disappeared.
To understand why, first, we have to look
at the language the Kremlin is using
to shape public opinion.
(Vladimir speaking in foreign language)
When officials in the media
talk about Russia's actions
in Ukraine, they don't use
words such as war and invasion.
(Vladimir speaking in foreign language)
(men speaking in foreign language)
The flip side is people
can be legally liable
for talking about peace in public
or promoting antiwar slogans.
(sirens ringing)
Like this detention in the
center of Moscow in mid-March.
A young man stood with a sheet of paper,
which at first glance,
didn't even look like an anti-war poster.
It just showed eight asterisks.
- These eight stars mean
(Dmitry chanting in foreign language)
or in English, no to the war.
- [Narrator] Dmitry Reznikov,
a sociology student at
a Moscow university,
is the man seen in this video.
A copy of the police
report reviewed by WSJ
said that Dmitry
discredited Russian forces
with his poster.
This is a violation under an amendment
to existing law that was
swiftly passed in March,
weeks after Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
Punishments now include
fines of up to the equivalent
of $12,000 for discrediting the army
and up to 15 years in prison
for publishing anything
deemed to be false information
about the war.
Dmitry was fined equivalent
to some $600 but he says
his poster has nothing
to do with discrediting the army.
- My poster expresses two main ideas.
The first one is pacifist position.
The second idea concerns
censorship in our country.
Today in Russia, any
publicly expressed opinion
that contradicts the position
of the government is a big risk.
- [Narrator] The word peace itself
is among those that can
discredit Russian forces
according to prosecutors in the country.
Maxim Selig was fined
the equivalent of $600
for holding a pack of ham.
He changed the logo to
read peace in Russian.
And Constantine Goldman stood silently
with a book of "War and
Peace" next to a monument
to the city of Kyiv near the Kremlin law.
He was detained minutes later
after a woman reported
him to a police officer,
found guilty of protesting
near the presidential residence
and fined according to his lawyer.
All three men pleaded not guilty.
- What this indicates is essentially
that nothing that might even be taken
as a sign of dissent is
allowed in Russia right now.
And so if you're even standing
in a public square
holding a piece of paper,
whatever that piece of paper says,
you're signaling to the public
that you're out there protesting.
(people chanting in foreign language)
- [Narrator] More than
15,000 antiwar protestors
have been detained since the start
of the invasion, according to OVD-Info,
an independence rights groups.
- It shows the great lengths
that the Kremlin is going
to to snuff out dissent
to make sure that its message
of unity behind the war
is coming across.
- [Narrator] The Kremlin didn't respond
to The Journal's request for comment
on arrests of antiwar protestors
and restrictions on freedom
of speech in the country.
Russian authorities have
said they hear those
who don't support their actions
and are working to explain
their goals in Ukraine.
In April, 74% of respondents
backed Russia's campaign
in Ukraine, according
to the independent pollster Levada Center.
Some sociologists say opinion polls
aren't necessarily accurate
in contexts where people are often afraid
to criticize the government.
Still, in parts of the country,
there continue to be small protests
and signs of dissent,
like this no to war sign
that briefly appeared
on the ice of St. Petersburg
and protestors say many
others like them disagree
with the government.
- The world should know that
there are a lot of people
in Russia who are against this war.
(dramatic music)